FRED SAUER: Let's see.
So how viable or recommended
would it be to build a backend
service for mobile apps around
Google Cloud Endpoints?
MANDY WAITE: All right.
OK.
So I think really that's
probably the biggest use case
for Cloud Endpoints, building
mobile backends.
And when we say backends, again,
we're talking about the
general sense of it,
rather than the App
Engine sense of backends.
If you want to build an
application that will provide
resources and services that
are consumed by mobile
devices, then Cloud Endpoints
will do that for
you out of the box.
I think pretty much we covered
most of that in the slides.
But the documentation's pretty
extensive, both for Java and
for Python.
So if you want to find out more
about how to use Cloud
Endpoints, you can
check that out.
And there's also a Google I/O
talk last year, wasn't there?
FRED SAUER: There was, yes.
MANDY WAITE: So you can
actually get a lot of
information from the
Google I/O sessions
from previous years.
FRED SAUER: Very good.
All right.
Your turn.
MANDY WAITE: My turn.